حبيبي من الباحثين اللي تخصصوا في شان
شيعه الخليج ااه
وصاحب قلم جيد
وعامل بعده مؤسسات اكاديميه كبيره همم لكن
اي بحث ياتي من خارج المنظومه حتى لو كان
ضاحي السعودي الان عبد الله لما اروح لو
اروح الى القصيم واحاول ادرس الاسلام
السياسي السني همم المجتمع همم راح يكون
حضر معي نفس الشيء لو تروح تدرس الفكره
اللي بيصير
بقدر انك راح تلاقي الكثيرين يتحاشون
ستلاقي بعض الذين يمثلهم تيارات معينه
يتوقفونك ويحاولون ان يمرروا
توما وهذا بالمناسبه وقع فيه سيف الله لكن
مو بالوضوح على الاقل بالنسبه
وجد قدامه تيار مشط اللي هو المعارضه
الشيرازيه السابقه سواء المعارضه لما زالت
نشطه في لندن وناخذ مثال كتاب الدكتور
فؤاد ابراهيم
الشيعه في المملكه العربيه السعوديه هذا
غير كتاب حمزه حسن طبعا هذا الكتاب في
الاصل باللغه الانجليزيه عن دار الساقي
وبعدين ترجم وطبعا في فرق بين نسختين
العربي والانجليزيه همم
كتب همم
توبي ورقه نشرها في المركز اللي انا باحث
فيها الان مركز الشرق الاوسط سنه 2010 عن
حزب الله الحجاز
تقرا الورقه من اولها لاخرها هو يتكلم عن
حزب الله الحجاز على هامش منظمه الثوره
الرئيسيه في الجزيره العربيه يعني العنوان
عن حزب الله الحجاز ولكن يتكلم عنهم على
الهامش تيجي نشوف مصادر
رواياتهم اخذ شويه من
فؤاد ابراهيم اخذ شويه من المعارضين
السابقين اللي رجعوا الى المملكه واستقروا
لان هم الجماعه بامانه يعني
المعارضه السابقه هي الجماعه
مررت الروايه الى كباحث غربي عامل في عده
همم يعني اكبر ثلاث جامعات امريكيه متخصصه
بريطانيا متخصصه في الشرق الاوسطيه بيمر
عليها كلها ف- اا روايه اصبحت اداره
مصداقيه اللي حصل بعدين كل من يكتب على
الاسلام السياسي وعن حزب الله الحجاز ياتي
يقتسم توبي الذي اخذ روايه جاهزه
وهذه اشكاليه كبيره لاحطها في عند توبي
يولام او لا يلام هذا شيء اخر